Let's look at the solution for
our Direct-Mapped Cache map access Quiz.
We have these four axises in this cache.
The cache block is 32 bytes.
And there are eight blocks in the cache.
So the address break down will
be the offset bits will be 5.
Because we need five bits to
tell us which of the 32 bytes we
are talking about.
The index bits will be three,
because we need
three bits to tell us which of
the eight slots in the cache to use.
And the remaining bits
are going to be the tag.
Now let's consider which of
these map where in the cache.
As you can see, the least significant
eight bits are going to determine
where in the cache something goes.
So we can conveniently look at just
the least significant two hex digits.
1F 0001 1111.
Five bits are the offset,
and 000 is the index.
So this goes here.
3F2F has 0010 here and
then 11111 but it goes to index 1.
3F2E has two and then E,
it also maps here.
Because it is actually
the same block as this one.
They will both be in this slot here
because really the entire block
3F2 something is there.
And finally 3E1F is
going to map to 001 F,
so the index is zero,
and it's a different
block from the one we had previously.
So this one will be replaced by this.
The final content of the cache
really is that the block
3E1 something is here and
3F2 something is here.